-You served with distinction,
won a couple of medals
for your service, but you also
were a local celebrity.
You had a show,
a television show in Iraq,
called "Moulton and Mohammed."
-"Moulton and Mohammed"
with my translator, Mohammed.
And -- I mean,
we were celebrities.
I mean, I used to get fan mail.
I used to have to sign
autographs in the street.
I mean, no one asks me
for my autograph now
as a member of Congress.
[ Laughter ]
So, this is a total step down
in terms of --
-And so here -- so here are you
and your translator.
That's Mohammad over there.
So what was the show?
Like, what did you guys --
you were --
What was the goal of
broadcasting in Iraq to people
who had obviously never had
non-state-controlled television?
-Well, it was amazing
because we actually believed
in the Marine Corps
that a free media
was important to a democracy.
Sort of a crazy concept
these days.
-Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-But -- But the first thing we
had to do is
we just had to get
something on TV,
because all this TV station
had ever done
was play tapes from the Ministry
of Information in Baghdad.
So the first thing we did
was we got a DVD player,
hooked it up
to their transmitter,
and these Iraqis
used to put in movies --
American movies
they would get from the market
and watch them
for the first time
while simultaneously
broadcasting them
to million of Iraqis
across the country.
And the mistake we made is
we forgot to
explain the rating system.
-Okay, gotcha.
-So what would happen is they'd
get to a racy section
of an American film,
and they'd quickly hit eject.
They had this 10-volume set of
Islamic history videos
that they would put in to sort
of calm everybody down.
[ Laughter ]
But one night they didn't switch
quickly enough.
The movie was "Basic Instinct."
-Oh, that's one you want to
switch, yeah.
-And so the next day,
there were protests.
I mean, men throwing rocks,
women wailing in the streets.
Mohammed, my translator and I,
just 'cause we were sort of
in charge of the TV station,
we got death threats.
At the end of a very long day,
I turned to Mohammad, I said,
"Let's just go -- let's go get
tea with the Iraqi police."
'Cause these are guys in their
20s and 30s.
Like, surely they wouldn't
be so offended
by what was on TV last night.
And it was a great
cultural lesson for me
because I walked into this room
full of young Iraqi men,
and they were immediately irate.
They were yelling and screaming
at me, and I turned to Mohammed
and I said, "Mohammed, what are
they saying?"
And he said,
"Sir, they say every time
you put a movie on TV,
you turn it off right
when we get to the good part."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-So a lot -- a lot of
similarities with 20-year-olds
here in the States as well.
One of the things you are hoping
to do is recruit
a new generation of people
in public service
that come from the military.
Veterans can have great purpose
here serving in office.
What is it about veterans
that you think
is important
for our political system?
-Well, look, I wouldn't be here
if not for being a veteran.
I mean, I didn't grow up
interested in politics
or anything like that.
I was actually recruited by
a non-profit
trying to get veterans to run
for office at a time
when we've never had fewer
veterans in Congress
in our nation's history
than we do today.
And when I decided to run,
it was because the Congressman
in my home district,
you know,
Congressman Bates' successor.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
-He managed to pass one bill
in 18 years.
He was incredibly partisan.
And I was like, look, if no one
is willing to stand up to him,
then the system
is never going to change.
So the problem is,
I was so naive about politics,
I didn't know that you're not
supposed to take on
an 18-year incumbent
in your own party.
And so the whole national
Democratic establishment
was against me.
They said,
"You're going to lose."
And by the way,
you will never run for anything
again in politics,
because you don't challenge
the establishment.
And fundamentally what they were
saying to me as a veteran was
do not participate
in the democracy
you risked your life to defend.
And that's wrong.
-And have you -- So you had
this interesting situation,
which is now you're in this very
partisan Washington D.C.,
but kind of
your first political battle
was against your own party.
Do you feel like that puts you
in a better situation
to deal with all of
these different --
-Look, the party establishment
has gotten us
into a terrible position
right now.
I mean, we don't control
anything in Washington,
and so I think it's time for
a new generation of Democrats
to step up and run.
And the thing about veterans is
they know how to
challenge the establishment.
They're not afraid to take on,
you know, the people in control.
They're not afraid to put people
over politics
or over their political party,
and I've got 19 unbelievable
candidates that I've endorsed
and encouraged to run
and everything.
People like Mikie Sherrill
right down in New Jersey,
who's taking on the chairman of
the House
Appropriations Committee.
I mean this -- The chairman of
the House Appropriations
has more money
flowing under his pen
than any politician
in the world,
and she just scared him
out of the race
because she's such an incredible
leader.
She's a Navy helicopter pilot.
-That's really --
-She's going to win.
[ Applause ]
And I think that, you know,
the problem right now is
we've got to look ourselves in
the mirror as Democrats
and recognize that we've lost.
Like, you know,
we stand for the right things,
but we've lost a lot of
elections,
and unless we're willing
to change,
unless we're willing to make
some difference,
unless we're willing to stand up
and talk about where we think
we should take America,
rather than just
bashing the Republicans,
let's talk about our vision
for America.
Let's talk about how we're going
to tackle the economy
and national defense.
Let's talk about what we're
going to do,
not just what Trump
is doing wrong.
-I think one of the things
that Trump did, obviously,
is he had these very bold policy
proposals in the 2016 election.
Now, whether or not any of them
were rational,
they were certainly bold.
What are -- Do you think in the
next, not only 2018, but 2020,
what are the bold
policy proposals
that Democrats need to take?
-Look, one of the things we have
to do is tackle the economy.
And the reality is a lot of
people in America
are getting left out
of the economy.
And it's not because of what
Trump says.
It's not because immigrants
are taking jobs.
It's because they're being
automated out of existence.
I mean, literally,
robots are taking jobs.
So rather than
take Trump's strategy of
let's go back into the coal
mines and pretend it's 1955,
let's actually embrace
the new economy
and talk about how
everybody in America,
no matter where you live,
has a meaningful role to play in
the economy of the future.
Let's talk about how we can
actually expand
healthcare access
to everybody in America
rather than quibble about
how many people are going to
lose healthcare.
You know, let's talk about
what a Democratic vision
of national defense is,
where we build alliances across
the globe and promote peace,
rather than try to start wars
with North Korea. I mean --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I -- That all sounds
very good to me.
I hope that everybody else wants
to hear that message as well.
Thank you so much for making
the time to come here.
-Hey, thank you, Seth.
-Thanks for taking care of
Massachusetts' 6th.
Congressman Seth Moulton,
everybody.